this is the uh Michael Jordan of all
watches over here what we have here we
got a Jay-Z wearing a paddock Philippe
5711 Nautilus with the Tiffany blue dial
you got that Tiffany stamp on there and
uh when you're wearing this piece you're
probably gonna know the person who's
wearing it also because you can't get
your hands on this the first one was
sold in auction for six and a half
million dollars and if you want to get
one today you're going to be probably
paying a hefty price tag of over 3
million Tiffany and Paddock when they
made this watch together they said let's
make 170 pieces to represent the amount
of years since our first collaboration
so imagine Tiffany and Paddock were
working for 170 years together and
they're paying homage to that
anniversary coming out with such a
unique piece